[Musique]
chaque jour des milliers de cargos
sillonnent les mers du globe
métronome du monde il rythme a marché
qui désormais ne supporte plus aucun
temps mort
chaque jour plus d'un million de marins
assure sans relâche des rotations
toujours plus rapide
samar aux avocats y est un de ceux là un
de ses ouvriers de la marine marchande
un de ces petits soldats de la
mondialisation
samar aura 26 ans sa vie est devenue
longue itinérance entre les cinq
continents et il ne quitte que rarement
le pont d'un bateau
[Musique]
sur mon île je ne faisais que pêcher
très neigeux tourné en
et puis que je voyage toujours
l'impression de découvrir chaque jour
tellement de choses
pour moi c'est une expérience
extraordinaire
[Musique]
de putis les marins ça marois embarquent
sur des cargos ou des porte containers
cette année il a navigué entre la mer de
chine et les côtes africaines
shanghai singapour bombay madras ou
encore abidjan ont fait partie de ces
escales régulière
[Musique]
son contrat s'achève à durban en afrique
du sud
il ne sait pas encore de quoi sera fait
son avenir
les marins comme ça marois enchaîne des
contrats précaires et ne sont jamais à
l'abri de lendemains qui déchantent
surtout en période de crise économique
j'aime bien la vie à bord je suis bien
j'aime le moment des escales tous ces
pays que j'ai découverte je crois qu'au
fond ce que je préfère c'est la vie en
mer le travail la vie avec l'équipage
pour moi le temps a passé vite j'espère
vraiment que je pourrai retrouver un
autre bateau un autre embarquement
en attendant un autre embarquement sa
marois regagne kiribati son pays l'un
des plus pauvres et des plus isolés du
monde
la moitié de la population via tarawa
pour cette jeune république indépendante
depuis 1979
la capitale est la seule porte d'entrée
sur le monde moderne
pour survivre kiribati a vendu sa zone
de pêche son pavillon de complaisance et
exporte les jeunes marins du marine
training center
une école prestigieuse qui forment ce
qu'on appelle ici les lucky number
ceux qui pourront un jour quitter le
pays pour se choisir une autre vie
ailleurs
[Musique]
il faut encore quatre heures de mer pour
rejoindre à beihang l'île natale de sa
marois où vivent toujours ses parents et
ses trois frères et soeurs
après un an d'absence ça marois retrouve
sa plage et son lagon ici rien n'a
changé
les jeunes de lille profite toujours du
bleu pacifique avec pour seul horizon un
atoll de quelques kilomètres carrés
seulement
depuis qu'ils naviguent sa marois a
découvert un autre monde et il veut le
faire partager à sa famille
[Musique]
c'est lors des retrouvailles des
retrouvailles publiques
ici pas d'effusion pas d' étreintes sauf
avec les plus jeunes
[Musique]
sous la paillote le fils peut alors
raconté au pair le récit de son année
passée en mer
mon voyage avaient plutôt bien commencé
mais ensuite sur le bateau j'ai été
blessé au dos c'était en afrique non
mais à l'hôpital là bas comme s'était
infectée il a fallu l'opérer et alors le
bateau bien entendu
non non il ne m'a pas attendu sur trouvé
en angola et l'armateur me renvoyer un
billet d'avion pour rejoindre hong kong
je restais là bas une semaine en
attendant de recevoir les papiers
[Musique]
de retour au pays sa marois a retrouvé
son ancien quotidien
derrière la carte postale les plages et
les palmiers une autre réalité
une jeunesse qui s'ennuient
[Musique]
le billard la messe et le lagon sont à
peu près les seules distractions
[Musique]
dans le village le retour de sa marois
n'est pas passée inaperçue
si la mappemonde qui l'a rapporté
n'attire que quelques curieux en
revanche son ordinateur portable
remporte un franc succès chez des
enfants
dans une île où la télévision n'existe
pas les dvd de sa marois en apprennent
plus sur le monde que n'importe quel
planisphère
pour boca y le père de sa marois toutes
les journées se ressemblent
il faut trouver de quoi nourrir la
famille dans les eaux du lagon bien sûr
le petit lopin de terre qui jouxte la
maison
quand il est à habas yang sa marois et
toujours mises à contribution
[Musique]
pour se nourrir par ici c'est simple on
cultive la papaye on va pêcher il n'y a
qu'en vendant un peu de coprah ou bien
des halles que l'on peut dégager
quelques revenus
bien sûr que ça marois partenaires ça
nous a aidés
il a pu nous envoyer de l'argent
et on a acheté d'autres soudan mange et
surtout on a payé les frais de scolarité
de ses frères et soeurs car ici
l'enseignement secondaire est payant
c'est une coutume chez nous quand les
enfants sont en âge de travailler ils
doivent prendre le relais des parents
pour aider à leur tour leurs familles
chaque mois sa marois on voit les deux
tiers de son salaire à son père
à kiribati la solidarité est un mode de
vie on apprend très tôt le sens du
devoir
une valeurs inculquées dans les familles
mais aussi sur les bancs de l'école
tâter à l'ancien professeur d'anglais de
sa marois connaît bien les jeunes leurs
aspirations comme leur sentiment de
frustration
avec les enfants ici sont vraiment isolé
ils vivent dans une zone très reculée du
monde
ceux qui n'ont pas pu quitter les rives
de laurine sont condamnés bien souvent à
rester ici pour le restant de leurs
jours
la plupart des jeunes se mettent à boire
de l'alcool à habas yang il n'y a pas de
bière ou d'alcool fort comme le whisky
ici ils se font eux mêmes leur propre
alcool qu'ils appellent le coq et ou qui
qu'il soit bon ou mauvais ne change rien
à la ferme c'est ce qu'ils boivent
[Musique]
les amis de sa marois comme l'immense
majorité des jeunes de kiribati ont tous
voulu partir mais certains d'entre eux
seulement ont pu intégrer le marine
training center l'école navale de tarawa
et parmi eux quelques-uns n'ont pas su
saisir leur chance
j'aimais tellement la vie de marin mais
je n'ai pas été assez disciplinés un
jour en mer
j'ai vu et j'ai insulté un officiel
ils m'ont viraient immédiatement
sans avertissement ils m'ont dit que
c'était fini pour moi
à partir de ce moment là j'ai dû revenir
à la vie ordinaire
la vie dans les îles
ma vie d'avant
la vie en mer me manque
et l'argent aussi
ceux qui n'ont pas encore eu l'occasion
de goûter à de nouveaux horizons ne
désespère pas d'y arriver un jour
moi j'ai déjà passé trois fois le
concours pour entrer à l'école navale
mais je n'ai pas été reçus
je vais quand même retenter ma chance
cette fois je prends des cours de maths
et anglais toutes les semaines
on verra bien
ça fait mal de voir mes amis obligé de
rester la vie qu'ils doivent mener pour
faire vivre leur famille malheureusement
je la connais par coeur
lacasse je sais ce qu'il ressent
ce matin ça marois est de retour aux
marines training center de tarawa
l'école qu'il l'a formé
il y retrouve it et qui est roux qui
était son instructeur
la direction lui a demandé de venir avec
un autre ancien élève raconter sa vie de
marin à la promotion sortante
vous avez le temps d'aller à terre
pendant les escales
pour mon premier contrat j'ai été en
chine en inde en malaisie
en afrique de l'ouest
mais ça ne veut pas dire que j'ai
visitées chaque pays
or il arrive qu'on n'est même pas le
temps de quitter le cargo tout dépend de
la vitesse des opérations sur place
parfois ça peut aller très vite
aujourd'hui de toute façon ne passe
jamais plus de vingt-quatre report
est justement par rapport aux escales ce
que je veux dire c'est parfois vous
voudrez allé à terre pour boire des
coups y coller il faut que vous sachiez
que personne ne vous en empêchera et que
vous serez alors les seuls responsables
de vos actes si vous ne rentrez pas à
bord at an vous serez sévèrement punis
et croyez moi votre contrat sera rompue
alors je vous demande les gars quand
vous serez à bord de ne pas faire
n'importe quoi et de vous imposer à vous
même une discipline de fer
voilà bonne chance à vous tous et
j'espère avoir l'occasion de vous
retrouver un jour au maire
[Musique]
avant de regagner à beihong sa marois un
dernier rendez vous dans la capitale
il doit rencontrer un armateur le
rapport de son dernier capitaine figure
dans son dossier
bonjour content de voir voir alors les
problèmes de santé ça va mieux vous avez
vu un médecin
oui il m'a dit que ça allait que j'étais
apte
après avoir travaillé
je suis impressionné vraiment je suis
impressionné
vous êtes bien noté domaine
un conseil soi même soyez moins timide
quoi fait des efforts en anglais et
posez plus de questions il ne faut pas
que vous ayez peur vous avez toutes les
raisons d'être fiers vous avez montré
tout le monde que vous êtes en train de
devenir un bon marin faut être fier de
ça non oui je suis fier bon je peux vous
dire que je vais tout faire quand vous
trouvez un nouveau contrat sur un autre
navire chef
ça marois va bientôt pouvoir reprendre
la mer
mais il devra se défaire de sa timidité
et d'un complexe d'infériorité qui si il
n'est pas le seul à cultiver sorte m la
plupart et gens d'ici sont extrêmement
timides ils n'osent pas parler aux
étrangers parce qu'ils ont peur de dire
quelque chose de stupide ou
d'inapproprié
c'est un vrai problème culturel c'est
comme ça que sont l'ensemble des gens de
kiribati
[Musique]
ça marois a décroché un nouveau contrat
de travail dans quelques heures il
quittera ses proches pour la dernière
fois il prend place dans la pirogue de
son père
ce qui était routine et habitudes
redevient un moment singulier
dont il veut conserver toute la mémoire
[Musique]
c'est ce que je faisais chaque jour avec
mon père quand je vivais ici
c'est vrai j'en avais marre à l'époque
mais aujourd'hui je me rends compte que
ça m'a vraiment manqué pendant la nuit
où je suis parti
alors j'en profite avant de repartir
parce que après ça sera trop tard
[Musique]
il faut du poisson en abondance ce soir
il y aura du monde pour la dernière
soirée de samara beihang
[Musique]
sa maman inviter les amis et les voisins
du village pour le départ de son fils
les au revoir sont l'occasion de parler
des voyages
ceux du passé et ceux du futur
cette fois je parle là en europe en
passant par hong kong
la dernière fois tu vois j'étais en
afrique en passant par la malaisie
singapour
mais là c'est l'europe
la conversation n'ira pas plus loin
le décalage est trop grand entre ceux
qui restent et celui dit pas
aujourd'hui un nouveau décor à tence à
maroua à hambourg
c'est la première fois qu'il va en
europe il doit embarquer sur un nouveau
cargo dans le grand port de la baltique
mais avant le départ ça marois une
journée entière pour découvrir la ville
comme un simple touriste
son visage sombre et soucieux quand il
est sur son île laisse place à de larges
sourires
quand j'étais gamin à beihang je rêvais
d'europe on en avait eu quelques films à
l'école
et là tout d'un coup je suis vraiment là
et je vois tout ça tous ces immeubles et
de cette modernité c'est fou
je te jure j'ai l'impression d'être dans
un film
[Rires]
pendant son dernier séjour en famille ça
marois n'avait pas souvent trouvé
d'oreille disponible pour écouter ses
récits de voyage ici les conversations
se succèdent sur la vie en mer pour
l'instant l'argent et les économies sont
encore au coeur de toutes les
préoccupations de sa marois
la carte de crédit je peux demander au
capitaine de nous donner de l'argent de
poche quand il sera en escale comme ça
je ne dépenserai pas trop
j'espère économiser un peu quand même
je vais gagner 300 dollars par mois j'en
donne 200 à mon père il faut qu'il me
reste un peu non
oui
[Musique]
sama roi prend la relève d'autres marins
en fin de mission il embarque pour les
onze prochains mois sur un porte
conteneur allemand qui appareille ce
soir
direction anvers puis gibraltar le canal
de suez et enfin le pakistan
pendant que les dockers achève les
opérations de manutention
sa marois découvre le bateau sur lequel
il va poursuivre sa vie
je suis heureux
je suis vraiment content d'être là
regarde je mets ma propre cabine ma
propre salle de bain
bon j'ai un peu le trac j'espère que je
vais être à la hauteur j'ai quand même
moins peur que la première fois
[Musique]
le cargo a gagné la haute mer direction
la belgique
c'est l'heure des premiers moments de
détente pour les hommes d'équipage
où
pour moi d'être ici sur ce cargo c'est
comme le début d'une nouvelle aventure
même une nouvelle vie
je suis heureux de pouvoir aider ma
famille en lui envoyant de l'argent mais
en même temps je ne vis pas du tout ça
comme un sacrifice
c'est vraiment la vie que j'ai toujours
rêvé d'avoir
je ne l'échangerais pas avec une autre
samara savoure le présent mais il n'a
pas abandonné la place qu'il occupe au
sein de sa famille il est resté l'enfant
du devoir celui qui subvient aux besoins
des siens
le prix de la liberté
le prix à payer pour s'inventer une
deuxième vie loin de kiribati
[Musique]